[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jeff passin covers baseball for espn he
joins us on the program
as we've been talking about spin rate
doctoring the baseball
what's illegal what's cheating you got
players calling out players
pete alonso the mets says there's a
conspiracy
theory to keep down salaries in certain
years
oh jeff let's sort through this when did
this become a story
a decade ago and i'm not exaggerating
when i say that dan i i
wrote a story when i was with yahoo
sports
i think it was eight years ago now i
wrote a story about how pitchers are
starting to
use sunscreen and rosin in order to get
a little bit of a sticky feel on their
hands and i don't know if you remember
this but
clay buckholtz was pitching at rogers
center
indoors and had sunscreen on his arm
that's when you knew there was an issue
here when clay buckholtz is running his
hand
his hands through his hair and he's got
like
jerry curl going on in back and you see
on his arm and he keeps going through
his arm
and there's sunscreen there in a domed
stadium i was like okay
you know ball players love to cheat like
that's just that's what this comes down
to
is it not is this not just a reminder
that baseball players
love pushing boundaries as far as
humanly possible
and that if you and i mean you
as major league baseball writ large give
a baseball player an
inch stand they will take a marathon
like that that's just what they do and
and how i think they're wired and
programmed and it's interesting
thinking about other sports like is the
desire
to push your performance to different
levels
doing things that are uh in a very gray
area
prevalent in any other sports i mean i
don't know baseball or i don't know
football and
basketball and hockey as well um
and i'd love to hear your answer to that
because i don't know if this is just a
thing
that's unique to baseball or if it
exists everywhere
but it feels like this just started to
uh escalate a month ago that that it got
really big and now
i watched garrett cole last night i
tuned into the twins yankees game
just to watch garrett cole on the mound
to see
what he did or what he didn't do a very
impressive performance by him but
now all of a sudden baseball is going to
be closely monitoring what pitchers
how do they do this what what what you
where are we
inspecting you inning by inning okay
i want to get back first to your first
question i say 10 years that's a little
bit of a flip answer because
this is something that's really
accelerated over the last
probably three years or so when guys
graduated
from sunscreen and rosin to some of
these
uh you know other substances and there
there have been pitchers out there down
who for
a while now have had their own like home
brew
um i mean i i have heard of one
who takes um like
a firm grip stick and melts it down
and mixes it with coca-cola and and
like cooks it inside of a coke it's like
i mean it's like baseball heroin and
they go out and use this
and get extreme spin and i think
you know when major league baseball did
not crack down
and essentially turned a blind eye to
guys
who were using increasingly sticky
substances
others all of a sudden are like well if
they're doing it
they're getting advantages that i don't
have and i don't want to get
passed by i don't want to lose out on
money i don't want my team to be
disadvantaged because of this
so i'm just going to join in the party
as long as the league isn't saying
anything about it
and that's the you know i don't think
this is the same as steroids
um i think the parallels though are that
players felt like they were going to be
missing out on opportunities or they
were going to fall behind if they didn't
do it
and the league because it didn't say
anything
emboldened players to do that how this
is going to turn out
it's going to be a disaster um i mean
umpires
who already have a contentious
relationship with players
are literally going to be tsaiing them
like
10 times a game and there are gonna be
some players
who get angry at the implication that
they might be cheating there are going
to be some players
who when they get caught which is bound
to happen
uh are denying it um you know if players
actually are
dan scared straight by the possibility
of being caught then if if
umpires aren't catching anyone it's
gonna look like they're not doing their
job
like they're just all kinds of
minefields
but major league baseball believes this
is important enough now
to make it a priority here's my problem
with this though jeff that
you know we want to have more offense oh
we got too much offense
now we want to have a little more of an
equal footing
oh wait they're too good on this side
now we got to help the hitters
so next year we're going to help the
hitters this year we've helped the
pitchers like
they're back and forth they got to make
up their mind what kind of game do you
want
and then enforce the rules because
somebody using an
illegal substance um it's called an
illegal substance
is that cheating like what it's varying
degrees
of cheating and and and then
like how much is too much how much is
just enough that we're gonna
allow you with the unwritten rules of
baseball
yeah i i look at it this way
if you have a rule that is written
either apply the rule or get rid of it
and if you are going to apply it
and player is going to break it
then that to me is cheating um
like it is clearly
trying to get an advantage on field over
an opponent
and you know doing so by hook or in this
situation by crook
and i you know in terms of baseball's
um helter skelterness
i i think in this situation there's
actually some nobility to it dan
um because i'm glad you tuned in to
watch baseball uh
a lot of people aren't and they
should be they should be incentivized to
watch shohei otani and watch jacob
degrom
and watch tatis and acuna and guerrero
jr
and watch juan soto and watch all these
really brilliant ball players
who populate the big leagues these days
but the game stinks right now and if you
ask
anybody and i mean anybody inside of the
sport they will tell you that
strikeouts have become too prevalent and
the game has slowed down
too much and that creating some action
in the game
is imperative for its long-term and
short-term survival
um and so to do something where
you make the pitchers a little less
dominant
i actually don't think that's a
problematic thing even if it does
continue on this trend
of trying to do too much or trying to
manipulate the game too much
i'm watching the yankees twins game and
they were showing batting averages and i
thought they were
telling you how much a player weighed i
i thought it was like oh he weighs 188.
oh he's 176. oh there's somebody who
weighs 235.
and then i realized oh my god these are
these are batting averages and you're
going okay
so there is something to this we had
fernando tatis jr on
yesterday and he said i'm seeing pitches
i've never seen before
now granted he's a young player but he's
saying
i'm at the plate and i'm seeing things
that i've never seen before
that to me sounds a little more alarming
than just
hey i need a little grip on the ball so
my my
slider doesn't get away from me right
and and these these two things
are interrelated because for a long time
i i think the reason that it's coming to
a head now
is the fact that the sport is hitting
237
and hitters are like okay enough
like for years pitchers have told us
that they need
some tack on the ball in order not to
let it
fly in order to keep things safe and i
do believe damn there's some
there's some validity to that because
what teams are asking pitchers to do now
and what pitchers feel like they have to
do
is go max effort and when you go max
effort
and you're throwing stuff with the arms
that guys have now
at 97 to 100 or you're trying to rip off
a slider
jacob's a crown who by the way i don't
think uses anything but jacob the ground
throws the slider
93 this slider is 93 miles per hour
it's silly stuff that we're seeing
across the game but
it transitioned from we need a little
bit of grip
to oh my god this grip
works really well i think i'm gonna go
and try and use some industrial adhesive
that strong men are using to lift atlas
stones
like that's where we are right now where
they've gone
and just taken something that made sense
and just taken it too far
as a former pitcher told me last night
he said
they're throwing frickin frisbees it's
like
wiffle ball and he said we're we're not
supposed to be able to do that with the
baseball
normally naturally you know what though
here's the thing
i don't want to just blame the stan on
foreign substances i think you're still
going to see
and here's here's the path i think it's
going to take i think a lot of guys have
been scared straight already and are
going to stop
i think there are going to be a few who
continue
using just the way there are some who
continue using steroids even when there
are penalties in place these days
you're still going to see nasty pitches
though because it's not
just the tacky stuff that's doing it
the technology more than the sticky
stuff
i think has led to this point and by the
technology
i mean guys go into labs
like literal pitch creation labs right
now
where they look at slow motion video of
what they're doing
where they're releasing the ball what
the spin is coming off
they do i mean they they put pressures
on different fingers and try to figure
out okay
how do i create this optimal pitch that
moves to get strikeouts that's where
most of it is happening right now
the sticky stuff just exacerbates it
it's always great to talk to you
see there's a benefit from this because
it
gave us an opportunity to talk to you
again jeff so
i i think it's a win-win for all of us
here thank you
baseball for cheating i truly appreciate
you
that's jeff pass and he's the baseball
insider for the mothership